Speaker 1: very differently than Joe Biden's
weekend. Donald Trump did a rally in Pennsylvania,
ostensibly to promote John Fetterman opponent
Mehmet Oz and Josh Shapiro's opponent,
Doug Mastriano. Ostensibly, I say because
every Trump rally is actually about himself
and Donald Trump coming out and says the
current president of the United States, right,
Joe Biden is the enemy of the state. He used to
say the media was the enemy of the people. Now he
says the president is the enemy of the state.
Speaker 3: As you know, this week,
Joe Biden came to Philadelphia, Pennsylvania,
to give the most vicious, hateful and divisive
speech. Ever delivered by an American president.
Speaker 1: Other than every Trump speech, I guess.
Speaker 3: Vilifying you 75 million
citizens plus another probably 75 to 150.
Speaker 1: Trump thinks there might be 225
million Trumpists in the United States want,
but he's never been good at counting that we know.
Speaker 3: To be accurate about it. As threats
to democracy and as enemies of the
state. You're all enemies of the state.
He's an enemy of the state.
Speaker 1: You want to know the truth.
So there it is, a former president calling the
current president an enemy of the state. And the
dystopian authoritarianism didn't stop there.
Trump also went on to say, without any evidence
that John Fetterman, the guy running against
Mehmet Oz, is taking all sorts of hard drugs.
There's no evidence of that.
Speaker 3: Fetterman supports taxpayer funded drug
dens and the complete decriminalization of illegal
drugs, including heroin, cocaine, crystal meth and
ultra lethal fentanyl. And by the way, he takes
them himself. It's completely out of nowhere.
Speaker 1: There's no evidence. I've seen that
Fetterman is making friends. I mean, it's crazy.
And part of this is this new, almost dictatorial
authoritarian thing that Trump is doing, which
is calling for the death penalty for drug dealers.
Speaker 3: They kill 500 people during a lifetime.
And I think it's much worse than that.
I think that's only what we hear about.
It would stop it if you didn't get it down
75, 80, 90% from day one. I'd be surprised.
And these committees that they set up,
it's laughable. It's a horrible thing.
We will solve that problem so fast. And
I'm calling on Republicans and Democrats
immediately to institute to get to Washington
and institute the death penalty for drug dealers.
You will no longer have a problem.
Speaker 1: And the crowd cheers,
which is maybe the scariest part. I mean,
listen, we know Trump loves dictators
and this. This is straight out of the Detroit
playbook. This is straight sort of out of the Shi
playbook. This is what dictatorial authoritarian
autocrats do. And Trump now openly saying
kill the drug dealers. And by the way, when Trump
was in power, he let numerous drug dealers out of
prison. He pardoned a former drug trafficker. He
pardoned 13 drug dealers during his last month in
office. So it's also total and complete hypocrisy.
Now, here is the point at which Trump's cognitive
state was questioned. Trump said that Facebook
founder Mark Zuckerberg last week visited Trump
at the White House and kissed his ass last week.
Speaker 3: You remember in the campaign, I used to
say, if these people get in, we're going to end
up with Venezuela on steroids. I said it many,
many times. I never thought it was much of a
possibility, but I never knew people could cheat
like that. Not like that. Last week. Weirdo is a
weirdo. Mark Zuckerberg came to the White House,
kissed my ass. What the hell is he talking about?
Speaker 1: And the audience finds it completely.
Last week, Zuckerberg kissed your ass
at the White House this morning. Sure.
Speaker 3: I'd love to have
dinner. Sure, sir. I'd love to
have dinner. I'd love to bring my lovely wife.
Speaker 1: All right. What a bizarre. I mean,
something is very wrong. Something very serious
is going on. If Trump thinks that he met with
Zuckerberg, it honestly, it reminds me of what?
This is sad. But later in Fred Trump's life, when
he was suffering very seriously cognitively, he
sort of worked in like a fake office. It was like
The Truman Show. Remember the great Jim Carrey
movie where Jim Carrey thought he was living a
normal life, but it was all stage managed for
him. They would like put papers on Fred Trump's
desk and they would have a phone where someone
pretending to be I mean, like I guess it was his
secretary, but they weren't really doing any work.
He would speak to his secretary on the phone.
It almost is like, is that what's going on with
Trump? Does Trump think, hey, a guy with a fake
curly hair wig. This is mark zuckerberg, sir. He's
here to meet with you. Oh, Mr.. Mr. President, we
want to go to dinner. Is it possible that there's,
like, a Truman Show type of thing going on with
Trump, or has Trump just have no idea what's going
on? It's very, very strange. And then in this
next clip, this is really interesting. In this
clip, you can really just feel the jealousy and
envy dripping off of Trump about Barack Obama.
Speaker 3: As an I got anywhere near I think
we got like 10 million more votes than
Obama got. Obama, you know. Oh, so popular.
So popular. He's so popular. They say he's so
handsome. Oh, Obama is so handsome. He's such a
great speaker. What does he say? He says nothing.
Speaker 1: So basically, Trump is very jealous
of Barack Obama because Obama is popular and
more handsome than Trump and a better speaker
than Trump. I mean, that's as childish
as this is. That's what he's saying.
And then this is beyond belief. Trump
criticizes Fetterman as being spoiled
for living off of family money. This is beyond
parody if you know Trump's background taxes.
Speaker 3: He is a spoiled and entitled socialist
loser who leeched off his parents money and lives
on the parents money until taxes. He is a spoiled.
Speaker 1: Yeah. And of course, Donald Trump
has basically his entire fortune because
of his father. Really, really wild stuff.
I was going to play the clip of the completely
unvarnished transphobia that is now a regular
part of these rallies. It's the exact same
three stories Trump always tells, you know,
the weightlifting stuff and the swimmer, and
that teachers shouldn't be allowed to teach
transgender. So I'm just going to skip it. But a
real tale of contrasts, the Biden speech over the
weekend and the Trump speech. Let's now look at
some of the people that went to the Trump rally